G1
E aí
[Música]
Oi
tá boa pode pegar escolas depois deixo
você
falei surpresa chamada princesa mais
linda que você Você pensa que eu fico
tão feliz eu eu estava todo Deus
tá Pensador acabou poupado Depois vem
falar com eu
e
beijar mas eu te amava mamãe depois eu
deixo você
manda o YouTube horas ebook mais grito
de chover você pensa porque tem que ser
assim
ele gostava tanto de mim
agora não me quer mais não pode mais
atrás não quer mais saber de mim
porque
ele só queria era comer você depois me
com medo que ficar contigo e quem
realmente ama você Você só chama de
melhor amigo ele só queria comer você
depois que o meu não publicar tio Lu eu
realmente amava você
Você só chama de melhor amigo
[Música]
por quê
Porque derr
E aí